welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the guy who
started the hashtag Snider cut for
Bieber and this video were breaking down
some amazing news in regards to the film
it's time to throw away your copy of
Justice League get your fake mustaches
out and Tommy do you read because we're
going through a big article from heroic
Hollywood sorry about that I was
terrible in the last year we've really
seen the release of the Snyder Kirk get
more and more hype surrounding it it
trended worldwide on the anniversary of
Justice League had numerous stars share
the hashtag released the Snyder cut and
Zack has been heading up his Bureau
account with images of the film there's
been a ton of back-and-forth around the
project and two weeks ago we reported
that Andy signor had posted an article
stating that the cut would not release
and that Warner Brothers were furious
with the director we did say that we
thought this wasn't true and now it
looks like it is numerous people have
come forth and stated that this is fake
news so it's looking worse than a CGI
upper lip for fandom wire right now
anyway throughout this video we're going
to be going through a new report that
looks like some amazing news for fans of
the film before we get into that though
make sure you subscribe to the channel
to never miss an update on the movie and
please drop a thumbs up if you're
excited for the announcement anyway
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the news okay so
as of the 17th of May website heroic
Hollywood posted a big report on the
progress of the movie I'll leave a link
to in the description below if you want
to read the full thing but basically it
goes through a lot of the characters
that were missing from the release as
well as the screening that Snyder
reportedly held for Hollywood execs it
says after Zack Snyder left Justice
League following a family tragedy Joss
Whedon was brought on board to help
finish the DC team of movie The Avengers
director oversaw the completion of the
film adding in his signature light
comedic tone and trimming the adventure
down to a two hour runtime most recently
Justice League cinematographer Fabian
Wagner claimed that the studio even
changed the color palette of the film
after Snyder's exit unfortunately
Justice League was met with a
disappointing critical reception and all
made a disappointing 657 million at the
box office reportedly losing Warner
Brothers 60 million fiber as of February
6th we have learned that Warner Brothers
were interested in revisiting the
project now the cost was always a point
of contention with the piece and I've
stated one of the main things holding
back the cuts release was because Warner
Brothers had already lost money on the
project and thus would have to take
another gamble people will argue about
what day it is on YouTube with you so a
stop saying this after a while because
for some reason there were accounts that
just wouldn't accept the main thing
holding back the Snyder Kurt was the
profitability of the project I've always
thought that in order to release it
Snyder would have to complete most of
the work his end and then the studio
would take the reigns for things like
VFX and additions that he was not able
to do on its own this was further filled
by a number of people confirming they'd
seen the cut including stunt coordinator
Eunice hood Hart and Jason Momoa Kevin
Smith also stated he'd spoke to people
who'd seen it and they'd said that it
was watchable from a production
perspective but that the VFX wasn't
finished this naturally built a lot of
excitement around the piece and every
time we get news like this it feels like
another milestone has been reached the
report states that in February 20 2002
film two executives who were interested
in seeing the current state of his
snyder cut they say it seems like a
recent screening of the film could lead
to a wider release heroic Hollywood has
exclusively learned and confirmed that
Zack Snyder held a private screening of
his cut of Justice League in the first
quarter of 2020 with executives from DC
in attendance according to an individual
with knowledge of the situation
something is happening with the Snyder
cut of the film and discussions are
currently underway we can take this one
step further and report that according
to our sources this screening took place
on Thursday February 6th no details
emerged about what came of the screening
but reports confirm it happened now what
this does mean is that Warner Brothers
are indeed interested in seeing the
potential at the movie holds that
anticipation is at an all-time high with
the project and it's hard to turn a
blind eye to the constant outcry for its
release the have been rumors that this
film is going to release alongside the
launch of HBR Max
I've always saw that this was a bit
stupid as there was absolutely no
promotional material to confirm this and
it had not been reported by a legitimate
source or even leaked there will be a
ton of eyes overseeing the streaming
service before it launches I think that
at some point we would have heard of its
existence if this had been the case that
doesn't mean I don't think it won't
eventually hit it but I think that the
rumors have been dropping with the
release of the platform or a bit and
found it it was rumored that Schneider
needed to shoot some additional scenes
such as the Martian Manhunter one and
also one featuring some of the key
characters I've always thought there's
no way in hell that they would get Ben
Affleck back but I guess we will see if
it goes ahead if it's just a couple of
days of shooting who knows but they
would also have to secure Henry Cavill
which yeah that's a totally different
video right there so it does seem like
the wheel's who are at least in motion
for the project however there's one big
spanner in the works that I think will
likely delay the release quite a bit and
that is the imposed quarantine that
currently exists in LA as the film still
needs additional VFX it seems highly
unlikely that things will be ready for
HBO max's release i would say with the
lockdown in place until august 2021
would be the release of the project at
the earliest it then has to be marketed
and the studio also has to decide
whether to release it through physical
media or on HBO max HBO max is not
available in the UK and thus they would
have to find an alternate solution in
order to get the film out there this
would add more complexities to the
production of the piece so I think it
will still be a while before the ball
gets fully rolling actually think what
may happen is that the film could even
end up being shown in an episodic format
across HBO max and then through
something like Amazon Prime video over
here the Curtis Room it to be over four
hours long and in order to drive
subscriptions and increase profitability
I can see Warner's wanting to milk it as
much as possible and drop the cut week
by week in as many episodes as they can
we all know it cost millions of dollars
the CGI our moustache and Warner
Brothers will likely want to recoup as
much as they can just should have just
let them have a beard like the comics
idiots
however they would also have to have
Schneider agree on this and he may not
want to slice up his film so yeah
a lot of things up in the air about the
project but at least they're getting
things going anyway cinema blend
followed up on this report by stating
that Schneider is now playing ball with
the studio and that he's currently
obeying NDA's and gag orders so this
could be why he stopped talking about it
publicly he even cut off the Batman V
Superman stream just before discussing
it so if we don't hear anything about it
for a while now I think this will be why
another interesting aspect that plays
into all of this that I haven't really
seen many people talking about is how
this will leave the stay of the DC EU if
it's successful
what if fans absolutely love the cut but
the DC EU is now on a completely
different track and this Warner Brothers
will have to make some changes dioxide
was originally supposed to appear in the
film and we've seen as confirmed by
multiple reports so I don't know whether
they would now keep this in the movie as
canon and move forward with the villain
as a big bad or merely introduce him in
New Gods yeah it's a very weird
situation and there is also of course
Batman after Affleck hit in the impasse
over his Dark Knight solo movie Robert
Pattinson was recast as the character
and though we don't know if the new
Batman film will be linked at the DC EU
it certainly makes things slightly more
complicated Snider's v film plans
sounded amazing but it's pretty much
been fully dropped now due to the
recasting and removal of certain key
elements of the DC you add to that the
studio has to decide what to do with
Amber Heard and Ezra Miller and you have
a lot of things with its release that
all need to be handled carefully the
reason that Warner Brothers waited 26
years to release their dick Donecker of
Superman 2 is because they wanted
everything to have settled and for there
to not be any problems going forward so
yeah overall just a lot of complicated
things I think with the Snyder cut
everything surrounding the movie is as
interesting as the movie itself and if
it does turn out to be a success it will
be intriguing to see whether it was
shaped the DC EU as we know it or if the
studio decide to remain on cause with
that current era
action I guess time will tell but let's
at least celebrate another hurdle being
crossed in terms of the film's eventual
release now obviously I loved hear your
thoughts on these updates if you think
they're true or not and what format you
hope to see it take make sure you
comment below and let us know and if you
enjoy this video then please drop a
thumbs up and make sure you check out
our breakdown of the new Batman rubber
pants an interview at the end if you
want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below
we massively appreciate you and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat to us after
the show either follow us at definition
whitey will click the discord link in
the description below every month you
give away free movies to people are
subscribed to the channel and this month
he can win the Marvel phase three part
two box set and all you have to do is
comment on a video and make sure you so
what no applications on the more videos
a comment on the more you have a chance
of winning so make sure you get involved
but when it's gonna be chosen at random
on the 15th of June and the set will be
shipped out from then to ever gets the
prize so best of luck to everyone who
takes part this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]